>> We've created our action, but it's not
going to actually show up on the page yet.
>> Got you.
>> So, if we scroll down to the Page
Layout section from the Objects That are Detailed page, this
is exactly the same thing. You know how we
click on the Edit the Page Layout from the record.
>> Mm-hm.
>> This is the other way to get to it, but from the set.
>> Edit.
>> So, we click Edit here. So, over here
we have Actions. There, you're way ahead of me, man.
[LAUGH]
>> I'm staying there, I think, figure this out.
>> Yeah.
>> Okay, so, oh, Add a Set Time.
>> So, this Publisher Actions area is where you
want to drag it, so let's put it in there. Oh.
>> It doesn't like it.
>> So we have to override the Global Publisher layout
first. There's, right now, you know we saw those actions already.
>> Mm-hm.
>> Those are the, that's the global layout. That's just what everything
automatically has. But if we override that layout, we can add in our
own custom actions.
>> All right. Layout overridden. Adding Set Time.
>> And, put it closer to the left, so we see it.
>> Oh, yeah, yeah, yeah.
>> Maybe after Post.
Awesome. So, now that we have that in the layout, let's check it out.
>> So, I'm visiting the Udacity Stage, and it says, Add a Set Time.
>> All right, yep.
>> That's it. Oh, that's cool. Okay, so,
I forget when our festival was, November 29th?
>> Yeah.
>> So, we'll have it set on the 30th. It's New, and
the time will be, let's make it 7:00, and the band, right?
>> Let's pick someone new.
>> Yeah. I've had it with these, these three boring bands.
>> What's the word? Try the Main Ten Ants.
>> oh yeah, I love them. Okay, and Create, and it worked. Very cool.
>> Awesome, so now, the Set Time record's created, and
people will know, hey, Andy created this at 6:16 p.m.
>> Mm-hm, cool.